* Sanfte schwermütige Klänge *
Reto nimmt
seit seinem 16. Lebensjahr Drogen.
Seit Jahren will er davon loskommen.
Einfach immer im Hinterkopf, wenn
ich heimkomme, etwas reinzupfeifen.
Samira hat
viele Fitnesswettkämpfe gewonnen.
Der Erfolg hat aber seinen Preis:
Sie hat eine Fitnesssucht,
schwere Essstörungen
und ist unzufrieden mit sich selber.
Zu dick. Ich weiss, ich kann anders
aussehen. Drum gefällt es mir nicht.
Cahit verspielt seit Jahren
sein ganzes Geld.
Verloren.
Er hat mit Schulden zu kämpfen
und ist allein.
Sie alle wollen eine Veränderung.
Weg von der Sucht,
rein in ein neues Leben.
* Einzelne
eindringliche Streicherklänge *
Hier in diesem Block wohnt Reto.
Ein Bier am Morgen
ist nicht sein grösstes Problem.
Sondern Heroin, Kokain
oder Benzodiazepin.
Es gibt kaum eine Droge,
die er nicht schon genommen hat.
Seit 25 Jahren
habe ich Drogenprobleme.
Während der ersten zehn Jahre
wollte ich gar nichts ändern.
Natürlich möchte ich
heute etwas ändern, aber wenn du ...
... von deinem Leben ...
Ich bin jetzt 41.
Von meinem Leben ...
Mit 16
habe ich angefangen zu spritzen,
hatte vorher schon
mit Drogen zu tun.
Es ist wahnsinnig,
das Leben einfach zu ändern.
Oder aber ich weiss nicht,
wie es richtig geht.
Seit seinem letzten Entzug
vor einigen Monaten
nimmt Reto keine harten Drogen mehr.
Als gelernter Metallbauer
sucht er einen Job.
Er möchte
eine Struktur in seinem Leben
und nicht immer
alleine zu Hause sein.
Aber mit seiner Vergangenheit
ist das schwierig.
Was soll ich denn machen,
wenn ich nur Absagen bekomme und ...
Bei jeder Absage, die du bekommst,
bist du auch irgendwie ...
... wirst du auch irgendwie ...
... demotiviert. Du fragst dich:
"Wozu bewirbst du dich überhaupt?"
Und dann ...
(Seufzend) Ja ...
* Einzelne Streicherklänge *
Ohne Arbeit und Tagesstruktur ver-
bringt Reto fast jeden Tag alleine.
Und mit jedem Tag, der verstreicht,
merkt er,
wie das Verlangen grösser wird,
wieder Drogen zu konsumieren.
So.
Es kommt wie eine Welle.
Es baut sich auf,
bis ein riesiger Druck da ist.
Was könnte diesen Druck lösen?
Das weiss ich auch nicht.
Sonst würde ich es machen.
Ich habe schon viel probiert.
Regelmässig geht Reto in der Klinik
Selhofen in Burgdorf in Therapie.
Ein Weg, den er gut kennt.
(Lachend) Mein zweites Zuhause.
Nein.
Du warst auch schon hier?
Und nicht nur zur Therapie.
Hier?
Zehnmal war ich stationär hier.
Und Reto spürt,
dass er bald wieder abstürzen könnte.
Welche Gedanken
haben Sie sich gemacht?
Ob ich nochmals irgendwie drei oder
vier Wochen hierher kommen soll.
Okay, erneut über das Stationäre,
worüber wir ... - Ja.
... auch schon gesprochen haben. Ja.
Aber es fehlt irgendwie noch
der letzte Dings, der letzte ...
Ich bin noch nicht 100 ...
Ich mache mir Gedanken darüber, habe
mich aber noch nicht entschieden.
Was wäre denn der Nutzen?
Was soll ein Aufenthalt bringen?
Es wäre wie ein Restart für mich.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich
früher oder später einen Job finde.
Davon bin ich überzeugt.
Stationär zu kommen
wäre eine Art Beschäftigung,
bis Sie dann
vielleicht einen Job bekommen?
Ein bisschen.
- Ja.
Wenn Sie hierher kommen
und dann wieder rausgehen
und trotzdem keine Arbeit bekommen,
könnte es dann wieder
ins Gleiche gehen?
Ja, natürlich.
Wenn er sagen würde:
"Ich muss wirklich nochmals inten-
siver an meiner Sucht arbeiten."
"Ich will wirklich davon wegkommen."
Oder: "Ich muss mir
über den Anschluss Gedanken machen."
"Ich muss irgendetwas verändern,
auch wenn ich keinen Job habe."
"Aber es muss
etwas anders sein für danach."
Denn wäre es für mich ganz anders,
als wenn er sagt:
"Ich will v.a. einen Job haben."
"Wenn ich einen Job habe,
ist alles gut,
und ich komme mal in der Hoffnung,
schneller einen Job zu bekommen."
Es gäbe Beschäftigungsprogramme
für Menschen in Retos Situation.
Schön, oder?
Er möchte aber einen richtigen Job
und so von den Drogen wegkommen.
Einfach immer im Hinterkopf, wenn
ich heimkomme, etwas reinzupfeifen,
das ist der Scheiss.
Ich drehe mich im Kreis,
seit Jahren.
Selhofen, dann kommst du
wieder raus, reisst dich zusammen,
dann stürzt du trotzdem wieder ab,
zwischendurch gibt es mal einen Job,
dann hast du einen Unfall.
Die nächsten Tage
werden entscheidend sein.
Entweder ändert sich noch etwas
oder es droht der nächste Absturz.
Das Gym ist ihre Welt. Die 25-jährige
Samira ist sechsmal pro Woche da
für ca. 2 Std.
Nicht ins Fitness zu gehen
ist für sie keine Option.
Für mich ist es schwierig,
einfach mal zu sagen:
"Hey, heute bleibe ich besser zu
Hause, weil es mir nicht gut geht
oder weil ich körperlich nicht
in guter Verfassung bin."
Dann ...
... weiss ich im Vornherein, dass
mein Tag grösstenteils gelaufen ist.
Also, mir ist das Training
schon sehr wichtig.
Es geht um Disziplin, um Kontrolle.
Manchmal auch um Zwang.
Samira will ihren Körper beherrschen.
Und sie ist streng mit sich.
Auf Instagram
hat sie über 20'000 Follower.
Kein Wunder: Von ihrem Körper
könnten viele Frauen nur träumen.
Und trotzdem
ist sie nicht zufrieden mit sich.
Was denkst du,
wenn du dich im Spiegel siehst?
Zu dick.
Weil ich mal Wettkämpfe gemacht
habe, ist das Bild anders.
Ich weiss, ich kann anders aussehen.
Jetzt bin ich halt ...
... gut 15-20 kg schwerer,
ja, 15.
Und ...
... dann gefällt es mir halt nicht.
Spitzensport gehört schon lange
zu Samiras Leben.
Bereits als Achtjährige
geht sie ins Kunstturnen,
trainiert viermal pro Woche.
Als Teenager beginnt sie mit Fitness.
Mit Erfolg:
Mit 22 ist Samira Miss Bikini,
Schweizer Meisterin im Fitness,
und holt einen vierten Platz
an den Weltmeisterschaften.
Samira hat ihren Körper im Griff,
isst strikt nach Plan.
Nach den Wettkämpfen
kippt es ins Gegenteil.
Sie hat regelmässig Fressattacken
und nimmt stark zu.
Ein Teufelskreis.
Heute leidet Samira
an einer schweren Essstörung.
Sie wiegt alles
und kontrolliert krankhaft,
was sie isst und was nicht.
Trotz oder gar
wegen der strengen Ernährung
hat sie immer wieder Essattacken.
Nachts.
Wenn sie alleine ist,
verliert sie die Kontrolle.
Bei mir ist es wirklich so extrem,
dass ich dann ...
... nicht mehr aufhören kann
mit essen.
Ich holte mir auch schon
nachts an der Tankstelle
oder am Selecta-Automaten
mehr Essen.
Ähm, ja ...
Das ist natürlich wie ein Rausch.
Man muss sich das vorstellen, wie
wenn man andere Drogen konsumiert -
gut, das weiss ich
ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Aber ich stelle es mir
ähnlich vor, weil man halt ...
... immer noch mehr
und noch mehr will
und es nicht aufhört.
Samira besucht regelmässig
einen Therapeuten, der helfen soll.
Seit einigen Monaten
ist sie aber 100 % krankgeschrieben.
Deshalb hat sie ihre Stelle
als Hochbauzeichnerin verloren.
Es hat überall, in
sehr vielen Bereichen meines Lebens
zu bröckeln begonnen.
Es waren nicht nur
die Ernährung und der Sport.
Es gab auch Berufliches
und Privates, das zu Bruch ging,
was mich aus der Bahn warf.
Mein psychischer Zustand
hat sich dann halt ...
... extrem verschlechtert.
Das hat sich durch Fressattacken
und Schlafstörungen geäussert.
Und durch Übertraining, dadurch,
dass ich nicht mehr schlafen konnte.
Mir war das dann alles zu viel.
Mit diesem Formular will Samira
ihr Leben jetzt von Grund auf ändern.
In einigen Tagen geht sie
für mehrere Monate in eine Klinik.
Ah, voila. So wäre es super.
Ab und zu ruft Reto
via Internettelefon an
und erzählt, wie es ihm geht.
Man gibt sich Mühe, oder.
Aber es gibt immer Phasen.
Manchmal geht es besser,
manchmal weniger gut.
Schon?
Aber jetzt geht es gerade gut?
Ja, jetzt habe ich
gerade eine gute Phase.
Ich habe irgendwie
auch nicht so Lust auf Drogen.
Ich will wieder mehr Sport machen.
Jeden Tag ein bisschen.
Ins Fitness, sozusagen?
Ah, jetzt ist gut, du.
Jetzt ist es super.
Jetzt ist es etwas weniger nervös.
Ich habe gerade gesagt,
dass ich versuchen will,
diese Woche möglichst
keinen Alkohol mehr zu trinken.
Nicht mehr saufen und so.
Es geht gut, ja.
Es geht mir fast besser.
Gestern und heute
habe ich nicht getrunken.
Einige Tage später. Die Anrufe
von Reto sind ausgeblieben.
Trotz der guten Vorsätze
hat er den Kampf gegen die Drogen
einmal mehr verloren.
Ja, leider wieder ...
... eben,
Absturz auf die Benzos gehabt
und ...
Sobald ich merke,
dass es aus dem Ruder läuft,
dass ich es
nicht mehr unter Kontrolle habe,
wann ich eins nehme
und wann nicht,
fühle ich mich unter Druck gesetzt.
Und das macht mich fertig.
Ich will es wegputzen.
Ich will diesen Scheiss nicht mehr.
Reto hat sofort reagiert
und sich für einen stationären
Aufenthalt in der Klinik angemeldet.
Jetzt muss er warten,
bis er eintreten kann.
Ja, es ist verrückt.
Das ist jetzt das elfte Mal.
Es ist mir selber peinlich.
Ich habe jeweils
diejenigen ausgelacht -
oder nicht ausgelacht, aber gedacht:
"Wow, der war schon
so oft im Entzug?"
Als ich selber
erst zwei- oder dreimal war.
Das sind diese Dormicum.
Dormicum ist ein
verschreibungspflichtiges Medikament,
das z.B. gegen Depressionen
oder zur Einleitung von Narkosen
eingesetzt wird.
Ein stattlicher Haufen.
Der Wirkstoff Benzodiazepin
macht schläfrig, entspannt -
und schnell süchtig.
Das Problem ist: Wenn ich es
nicht nehme, beginne ich zu zittern.
Und darauf habe ich keine Lust.
Normalerweise nimmt man
das Dormicum als Tablette.
Gemahlen durch die Nase
wirkt es aber schneller und heftiger.
Ah.
So.
Spürst du jetzt sofort etwas?
Es brennt einfach in den Augen,
oder. Ja.
Aber jetzt nicht,
dass ich direkt ...
... einhängen würde oder so.
Wobei ich finde, dass auch die Qua-
lität der Tabletten abgenommen hat.
Mit der Dosis, die Reto nimmt,
würden die meisten Leute flachliegen.
Er kann weiterhin
einigermassen funktionieren.
Da rein.
Reto will Pilze fürs Abendessen
sammeln.
Schau, da sind schon welche.
Ich kenne sie nicht. Ich esse
nichts, was ich nicht esse.
Mir würden zwei oder drei schöne
Steinpilze schon reichen, weisst du.
Hast du gesehen?
Plötzlich wimmelt es davon.
Maronen .... Maronenröhrling.
Schon wieder einer.
Das ist ein Rotfüsschen.
Die schlechten Teile weg und
dann los - ab in die Pfanne damit.
Wenn ich mal
irgendetwas angefangen habe,
habe ich Mühe mit aufhören -
egal mit was, fällt mir auf.
Ob mit saufen, Pilze sammeln,
mit Sport, mit ...
Ähm ...
Drogen und was weiss ich.
Ich höre einfach nicht mehr auf.
Das ist das Problem.
Was bedeutet dir die Natur?
Die Natur
ist ein Kraftpunkt für mich.
Ich war mit meinem Vater
oft in der Natur.
Er hat mich viel
über die Natur gelehrt.
Irgendwie, wenn ich in der Natur
bin, habe ich manchmal das Gefühl,
dass ich mit ihm zusammen bin,
oder so.
Wie wichtig war er?
Er war mein Vater.
"Wie wichtig war er?"
Er war für mich zu der Zeit
die wichtigste Person.
Als Reto elf Jahre alt war,
erkrankte sein Vater an Lungenkrebs
und starb kurze Zeit später.
Du sagst immer, das sei ein Wende-
punkt gewesen, als er starb. Oder?
Ja.
Wenn dir mit elf Jahren
das Liebste entrissen wird
und du es nie mehr wieder siehst.
Da möchte ich andere mal sehen.
Ich will nicht immer
über meinen Vater sprechen.
Der ist gestorben.
* Sanfte gläserne Klänge *
Es dauert noch ca. drei Wochen,
bis Reto
endlich in die Klinik eintreten kann.
Bis dahin muss er alleine
mit seiner Sucht
irgendwie seinen Alltag bewältigen.
* Sanfte gläserne Klänge *
Das ist Cahit.
Er ist 46-jährig und türkisch-
schweizerischer Doppelbürger.
Cahit wohnt in der Stadt Zürich
in einem Einzimmerstudio.
Er ist oft alleine.
Auch Eltern und Geschwister
besuchen ihn nur selten.
Der Grund: Cahit ist spielsüchtig
und hat das Vertrauen seiner
Verwandten immer wieder missbraucht.
Manchmal ...
... habe ich von meinem Bruder
oder von Kollegen Geld ausgeliehen
und habe dann
mit diesem Geld gespielt.
Und jetzt haben sie ...
... irgendwie kein Vertrauen
in einen Zocker.
Weil du ihr Geld
nicht mehr zurückbezahlt hast?
Genau.
Seit 15 Jahren ist er spielsüchtig,
arbeitslos und einsam.
Seine Sucht hat ihm alles genommen.
Finanziell ist er
von der Sozialhilfe abhängig -
und von Geld von den Eltern.
Er kämpft mit Depressionen.
Trotz seiner Situation
spielt er immer wieder.
Weil er unterdessen
in allen Casinos gesperrt ist,
v.a. mit Sportwetten via Handy.
Wie viel hast du draufgeladen?
10 Fr.
Das ist ja nicht so viel.
- Ja.
Bei Sportwetten ...
... setze ich weniger als ...
Ich sage jetzt mal 10 Fr.
Alle zwei bis drei Tage.
Einer davon
ist Galatasaray gegen Fenerbahce.
Ich bin auch Fenerbahce-Fan.
Die sind aus Istanbul.
2:2.
Ich habe auf zwei für Fenerbahce ge-
tippt, jetzt ist 2:2 unentschieden.
Das heisst?
Verloren.
Ja.
Früher spielte er in echten Casinos.
Hat auch gewonnen -
und das nicht zu wenig.
Das Geld
habe ich auch alles verspielt.
Ein paar Hunderttausend?
Ja.
Schon, ja.
Das ist viel.
- Ja.
Das ist viel, ja.
Regelmässig ist Cahit in der
Langstrasse in Zürich im Ausgang.
Es ist wie ein Zuhause.
Aber hier kann man auch
überall Geld verspielen.
3'000-4'000 Fr.,
die man am einen Ort gewinnt,
ein paar Tausend Fr.
Dann gehst du zum nächsten
und verlierst einfach alles wieder.
An jeder Ecke ein Kiosk,
an dem man legale und auch
illegale Online-Games spielen kann.
Mit der Kamera reingehen will Cahit
zu seinem eigenen Schutz nirgends.
Wann hast du gemerkt,
dass du ein Problem hast?
Vor Kurzem habe ich
von meinem Bruder Geld verlangt.
Ich habe gesagt: "Ich brauche Geld."
Er hat mir
seine Kreditkarte gegeben.
Die ganze Nacht, bis am Morgen ...
Ich ging 4'000 Fr. ins Minus
auf der Kreditkarte meines Bruders.
Dann habe ich gesagt:
"Ich stecke wirklich ...
wirklich tief in dieser Sucht."
Seit diesem Erlebnis will Cahit sein
Leben wieder in den Griff bekommen.
Aber zu Hause in Zürich
lauert die Verlockung überall.
Und trotzdem:
Weg von hier will er nicht.
Ja.
Ja, dann muss ich
die Stadt verlassen, ja.
Ich bin ...
... halt hier aufgewachsen.
Irgendwie kann ich das auch nicht.
Der Kollegenkreis und v.a. die
Familie leben ja in dieser Stadt.
Also ...
* Salsaklänge *
Samira
bricht heute auf in die Klinik.
Wie geht es dir heute Morgen?
Wieder etwas besser
bzw. war es die ganze letzte Woche
für mich ziemlich schwierig,
mich mit dem Ganzen abzufinden,
quasi.
Aber, ähm ...
Ja, ich habe
jetzt einfach versucht ...
... mir das Ganze schönzureden,
quasi.
Also, ich erhoffe oder wünsche mir,
dass ich in dieser Zeit eigentlich
wieder zu mir selber finden kann
und wieder lerne,
das Leben zu geniessen,
ohne mich
irgendwie gezwungen zu fühlen.
Zwei bis drei Monate
will sie in der Klinik bleiben.
Sie geht v.a.
wegen ihrer Essstörung in Behandlung.
Trotzdem nimmt sie
ihr eigenes Essen mit.
* Sanfte dumpfe Klänge *
Die Klinik Barmelweid
in Erlinsbach im Kanton Aargau.
Eine Spezialklinik für psychosoma-
tische Medizin und Psychotherapie.
Während der nächsten Monate
Samiras neues Zuhause.
Ich mache kurz die Tür zu.
Das wäre Ihr Zimmer.
Hier haben wir eine Glocke.
Wenn Sie etwas von uns brauchen,
können Sie sich damit melden.
Okay.
Dann haben Sie ein eigenes Bad.
- Okay.
Das wäre dort vorne.
Ah ja, okay. Super.
- Ja.
Noch die Schuhe ausziehen zum Wägen.
Auf fünf oder ...?
- Ja, ja, vier.
Abrunden auf vier.
- Vier, fünf.
Sind Sie 1.63 m?
- Ja.
Gut.
Essen muss Samira
von nun an auf der Station.
Sie wählt täglich
zwischen drei Menüs.
... was bestellt worden ist.
Wir haben mal
das Standardessen angewählt.
Sie können schauen,
ob das für Sie passt.
Dann esse ich einfach,
was mir schmeckt?
Ja.
Schweinefleisch mag ich z.B. nicht.
- Mögen Sie nicht, okay.
Dann lassen Sie das
heute ausnahmsweise mal aus
und wir werden vermerken,
dass Sie kein Schweinefleisch essen.
Gut.
Das Brot können Sie direkt löschen.
* Lachen *
- Okay, gut.
Salat ist gut,
aber das Brot muss nicht sein.
Das Essverhalten von Samira
soll sich ändern.
Mit ihren Therapeutinnen
schaut sie ihre Situation an.
Es freut mich, dass Sie sich
zu einem stationären Aufenthalt
entschieden haben.
Können Sie das Problem benennen?
Was war der Grund für den Klinik-
eintritt? Aus Ihrer Sicht.
Ich habe gemerkt, dass es
für mich nicht mehr normal ist
bzw. ich den Alltag und das Leben
nicht mehr so geniessen kann,
wie ich das mal konnte.
Ich habe auch gemerkt,
dass ich meinen Selbstwert extrem
vom Training abhängig gemacht habe.
Dass ich mich schlecht gefühlt habe,
wenn ich nicht trainiert habe.
Es war ein Teufelskreis mit
Schlafstörungen, Essen und Training.
Genau.
Wer schlecht schläft,
kann nicht richtig trainieren.
Dann habe ich wieder gegessen,
habe mich wieder schlecht gefühlt.
Habe wieder das Gefühl gehabt,
ich müsse ins Training.
Ich geriet immer tiefer rein.
Ich hatte das Gefühl: "Das kommt
wieder, das legt sich wieder."
Irgendwann,
als ich noch 100 % arbeitete,
ist das einfach alles irgendwann ...
Es begann überall
immer mehr und mehr zu bröckeln.
Und ...
Ja.
Deshalb.
Sie beschreiben das
sehr eindrücklich.
Sie ist sehr ehrgeizig,
sehr diszipliniert ...
... und auch sehr leistungsfähig.
Auch wenn es momentan
nicht mehr so ist.
Das ist ein bisschen der Klassiker:
Man kann sagen,
dass generell bei Spitzensportlern
sehr schnell -
oder nicht sehr schnell, aber
dass bei den psychischen Störungen
die Essstörung
an erster Stelle steht.
Meistens sieht man das bei
diesen Sportlern nicht wirklich,
weil sie natürlich
einen athletischen Körperbau haben.
Eine Essstörung
entwickelt sich dann kontinuierlich.
Am Schluss
hat man dann diese Essattacken.
Gibt es etwas,
das für Sie nicht passieren darf
während des stationären Aufenthalts?
Für mich wäre ganz schlimm, wenn ich
gar keinen Sport mehr machen könnte.
Aber ich möchte nicht mehr,
dass es so wichtig ist,
dass ich mich davon abhängig mache.
- Ja.
Aber trotzdem wäre es gerade
zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt schlimm,
wenn ich hier rauskäme und ...
... und 5-10 kg schwerer wäre
oder ...
... vielleicht auch
10 kg leichter und ich sehe,
dass meine ganze Muskelmasse
weg ist.
Das wäre das Einzige.
Aber sonst habe ich
eigentlich nichts zu verlieren.
Heute darf Samira noch
ihr eigenes Mittagessen essen.
Aber morgen ist damit Schluss.
* Dumpfe Klänge *
* Vogelgezwitscher *
Auch Cahit will sein Leben
endlich in den Griff bekommen.
Er besucht eine Therpaie.
* Ruhige Gitarrenklänge *
In den letzten 15 Jahren
habe ich viel zu viel verloren.
Nicht nur Geld.
Auch psychisch geht es mir
schlecht, habe immer Depressionen,
ich bin nicht mehr
in meinem Kollegenkreis,
ich stehe meiner Familie
nicht mehr nahe.
Machen Sie
jetzt noch Schulden damit?
Nein, Schulden mache ich nicht.
Nein, nein.
Es ist wichtig, dass jetzt
der Teil der Therapie kommt,
in dem wir wirklich konkret
die Tagesstruktur,
konkret die Partnersuche,
konkret die Arbeitssuche,
all das besprechen.
Sie sind motiviert,
da rauszukommen, ja?
Ja.
Und ...
Es ist nicht zu spät,
um rauszukommen. - Mhm.
Also:
Dann beginnen wir
mit der linken Seite.
Den linken Arm anspannen.
Nichts forcieren.
Jetzt können Sie entspannen.
Eine Entspannungsübung
ist der erste Schritt.
* Sanfte, beruhigende Klänge *
Mit frischem Wind
will Cahit jetzt vorwärtsmachen.
Erster Schritt: Jobsuche.
Er arbeitet zwar
ab und zu als Pizzakurier,
mit Hilfe der Sozialdienste will er
jetzt aber sein Dossier aufpeppen.
Was musst du dort machen?
Einen Job suchen.
Alles, Lebenslauf,
Arbeitszeugnisse zusammenstellen.
Dann Bewerbungen schreiben -
vielleicht dann.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Ich, äh, ja.
Da ist der Lebenslauf drauf.
Das ganze Leben ist da drauf.
Ohne Job ist es mir
im Moment verdammt langweilig.
Bewerbungen schreiben, ein Job,
das ist sehr wichtig, ja.
Willst du wirklich arbeiten?
Hast du Lust?
Ich habe Lust, ja, doch.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Cahits Traum: ein Chauffeurjob.
2 Std. später ist er schon fertig.
Nächste Woche habe ich den
nächsten Termin, dann schauen wir.
Vielleicht ein paar Bewerbungen
schreiben, Inserate anschauen,
Jobinserate, dann ...
... schauen wir weiter, ja.
Nur wenige Tage später: Cahits Eu-
phorie ist bereits wieder verflogen.
Seine Kiffervergangenheit
hat ihn eingeholt.
Vor einigen Monaten
fuhr er unter Cannabiseinfluss Auto
und wurde erwischt.
Jetzt ist er den Führerschein los.
Am Anfang hiess es: drei Monate.
Aber sie haben ihn mir
auf unbestimmte Zeit entzogen.
Jeder Zweite in der Schweiz kifft.
Oder ein Viertel.
Das macht sie ja ...
Ich denke, die fahren auch alle.
Aber ...
... ich bin jetzt der Pechvogel.
Oder wie nennt man das?
Ich bekomme jetzt ...
Siehst du dich als Pechvogel?
- Ja.
Ohne Auto kann er auch nicht mehr
als Pizzakurier arbeiten.
Wie gesagt, ich habe abends
als Pizzakurier gearbeitet.
Das war für mich eine Beschäftigung.
Und ich habe etwas Geld verdient.
Jetzt kann ich das auch nicht mehr.
Leider, ja.
Ein Rückschlag?
- Genau.
Dazu kommt:
Ohne Führerschein
ist für die nächste Zeit auch
sein Traum vom Chauffeurjob geplatzt.
Reto kann heute endlich
in die Klinik.
Es wäre eigentlich Zeit,
aufzubrechen.
Ai.
Weisst du, wenn man dort
5 Min. zu spät ankommt ...
Wie spät haben wir denn jetzt?
Zehn nach. Elf nach.
Also, jetzt gebe ich alles,
was ich kann.
Und wenn wir zu wenig haben,
sage ich ihnen,
ich hätte vergessen, in meiner
Scheibe drin zu wenig einzupacken.
Fertig.
Wenn Reto zu spät in die Klinik geht,
ist das gar nicht gut für ihn.
Wenn ich nicht erscheine ...
... könne ich
direkt zu Hause bleiben
und dann hätte ich
30 Tage lang eine Sperre.
In seinem Zustand
wäre das eine Katastrophe.
Dazu kommt: Reto will unbedingt noch
eine letzte Dosis Dormicum nehmen,
vor dem Eintritt.
Kannst du das
bitte irgendwie verstauen?
Zack, die ganze Fuhre dabei, wie?
Wenn es gut läuft,
sind das die letzten Dormis,
die du in deinem Leben nimmst, oder?
Herr Jesus, ich bitte dich,
gib mir die Kraft,
dass du mir ...
... hilfst, dass das die letzten
Dormicum in meinem Leben sind. Amen.
Ja, wenn es ...
Äh.
Eigentlich gehst du in die Klinik,
um genau davon wegzukommen?
Etwas paradox,
dass du jetzt welche nimmst.
Nein, nein,
das ist überhaupt nicht paradox.
Denn dein Hirn denkt:
"Oh, jetzt machst du das dort."
"Dann darfst du nie mehr. Also
jetzt noch ein letztes Mal, bitte."
Ihr Leute stellt Fragen und Fragen.
Dabei wüsstest du es ...
Du hättest ... Die Antwort
hättest du dir selber geben können.
* Hektische, helle Klänge *
Nächstes Mal geht Reto
mit letzter Kraft in die Klinik.
Morphin zeigt an.
- Ja.
THC zeigt an.
- Mhm.
Und Kokain zeigt an.
Ich tue da nur etwas komisch.
- Tun Sie etwas komisch?
Cahit will
sich ins Leben zurückkämpfen,
verfällt aber wieder
seiner Spielsucht.
Ich habe Geld bekommen.
Nach ein paar Tagen oder schon
nach ein paar Stunden war es weg.
Und Samira kämpft in der Klinik
mit verschiedenen Problemen.
Gestern hatte ich eine Fressattacke.
Ich ass alles,
was ich noch im Zimmer hatte.
Ich habe jetzt schon
Bammel vor dem Mittagessen.
Keine Ahnung, was kommt.
Keine Ahnung, was ich davon
essen kann und werde.
Ich vermisse das Gym.